He was the Best high School Player that ever [Played] in The State [of] Indiana he was the Phenom in The Basketball Craze [Stake]?
Every Time
We went Into sold out News Helicopter Landed on the Baseball Field but it was like Going to a rock Concert
He's damon Bailey the Minute he hit high [School] ball
We'll Never know how good damon
Might have Been as the next great Player
Indiana in
1985-86 When Damon Bailey was an eighth grader Bob knight went to Watch him play
Quite Honestly That's Probably When everything kind of Blew Up to be recognized
Nationally as an 8th grader back you know 30 Years Ago it just Didn't happen
We [knew] at A very Early age he, was a good [player] he?
Was A step ahead of Everybody on the Floor?
all of A sudden you know coach knight walks Into A gym it, was [Is] that God Had Walked, Into the Building [I]
Wrote About Night and How enamored he, was of damon [I] guess that, was the Beginning of the damon Bailey?
Phenomenon
Back Then
Just the Thought of Bob knight going to See an Eighth Grader Play Basketball, was?
Mind-Boggling
People That aren't from Indiana
They don't get it
People Would not leave Damon alone it was Almost Larry [Birdland]
People Coming Through
Picking Grass out of your yard as a Kid he Had become a Folk Hero
Adult Would Come Up to him and ask him for his, Honor
Bob knight Said damon was Better at that Moment as an 8th grader Than Any guard Indiana Had and
When you're built up the way he, was built Up I?
Imagine the Pressure was immense
However I, don't like it ever Affected him Nothing Seemed to Phasing
Well Damon Bailey, was Certainly a Phenom There's no doubting that
The Amazing Part of it was when People came to Scene
They Were Rarely Disappointed When they Left I'm the All-Time leading Scorer in The State of Indiana With over 3,000 Points
Gatorade Indiana Player of the Year
Four-Time Allstate First Team Player
McDonald's All-American Mr.. Basketball in Indiana Naismith High School Player of the year award usa, Today's all-decade Player of the year
I'm sure There are Others There but Those are the highlights
He was an extraordinary High School Player?
Who Made his last high School Game in The Hoosier Dome
The Fabulous Bailey Area Closes on the Saturday at A national High School Record for Tennis
41,000 for The Championship Game the Team, We were Playing was Undefeated he Just? Wouldn't be Tonight we?
Were six down With two minutes to go in the game all damon was about all he was Concerned About was Winning
Damon Proceeded Score The Last 11 Points of the game for us, we ended up winning by [3]
If hoosiers Hadn't been Made Already he Could have made a Movie out of that
And he Is an
Honest-To-Goodness Bolt he Wrote
Damon [he] Came in One day and Said I'd I want to go ahead and Commit to [iu]
You go to India University at that Particular Time you're going There [to] win A national Championship
When knight Said that his Career was a Disappointment I think that hurt Him and it was unfair
Damon Bailey gave Him Everything he Possibly Could as a player but he got hurt and was Really Never the Same
There'll Be A Lot of People out There They Can
Question How Good You were and I think I've won more games at any University Than Any Player that's ever Played There Those are the
Ones That Nobody's Gonna Take away from me
If Given [The] Opportunity in the right
Situation He Would Have been A very good Player and I don't think that ever Really happened for him
He's not going to be in The Basketball Hall of Fame but Certainly Anybody who calls him A Bus Didn't Watch him Play
do I regret Anything
No and I want to Make A lot [of] Money because I Can play the game of Basketball
[I] don't have to Make Decisions Based on Whether I cared Whether I talked to you or not?
All the hoopla that he Went Through [he] Didn't ask for any of it
And I know it Had to be Hard Point
The People that you know Think I'm the Prodigy you know They're Probably Wrong and the People who think
I'm A bust or probably wrong as, well